a College commencement speech going off
the rails with radicalism liberal City
University of New York is taking a lot
of heat after allowing a graduate to
give a speech that attacks the police
and the military and calling for a
revolution against what she claims is
the legal system's white supremacy
those who brought the ferocity of the
violence those who carry
the revolution the people the masses
those who brought the ferocity of the
violence those who need our protection
they will carry this revolution no
longer are we going to capitulate to
oppressors no longer are we going to put
our hope in their depraved Consciousness
the law is a manifestation of white
supremacy that continues to oppress and
suppress people in this nation and
around the world
you know Jesse I don't know what law
she's talking about but I went to law
school and so did Harold uh I doubt we
would agree with what that graduate said
but she was selected by the students at
the City University of New York an
accredited law school and I mean is that
woman and the speech that she made
reflective of what the graduating
lawyers are thinking probably we're
euthanizing ourselves as a country she
is from Yemen this is a poverty-stricken
war-torn country rocked by terrorism
drought famine the United States has
poured four billion dollars in Aid into
that country military aid
food assistance so she comes over here
we save her life probably grew up in
Queens we educated her we kept her safe
and she comes out of here and delivers a
really venomous attack on everything
that has made this country great
capitalism
the free market system the pillars of
this country the foundations of this
country she wants to destroy we're
educating this woman with our tax
dollars and she repays Us by saying
thank you now we're going to destroy you
this woman is a problem a half cocked
Cable News host would say that lawyers
are the new terrorists
I wouldn't go so far as to say that but
what I'm saying is people are saying
that Dana what about the fact that she
is a future lawyer we combine that with
some of the law students who are
objecting to the federal judge yeah who
came in and spoke there I mean that's
but that's actually what I had written
that down because so that was at
Stanford right and remember there was a
professor there and I think that she was
put on leave yes she wasn't fired the
story went away yep pretty sure she'll
probably be back there teaching in
September then there was the other one
remember all the students that were
obnoxious I believe that was at Harvard
Law School and there were judges
actually saying we shouldn't hire any of
these people we shouldn't allow them to
clerk I when I first saw this story this
morning I thought okay they had that the
school had hired a speaker to come on
and that they should be furious because
isn't a graduation speech supposed to be
about you've achieved such an amazing
thing you have a bright future in front
of you I'm excited for you
congratulations but instead I found out
it was it's the students that voted for
her yeah so what happened to the
graduation speech that's all about
inspiration yeah I would that's one
reason to get the money back but there's
another serious part of this so ilhan
Omar is a congresswoman from Michigan
sorry Minnesota and there was an attempt
by members of Congress to censure her on
the house where it didn't actually come
to that but even Democrats were saying
wow you have gone way too far in these
anti-semitic tropes I remember I don't
want to do it so yes you do remember it
well sorry yes of course
um
what this young woman was saying and
again she might believe it but because
this University is funded by taxpayer
dollars you have many people including a
lot of the Jewish groups saying they
should just be stripped of their funding
because they allowed this to happen but
the interesting thing Greg is that they
the the school took the speech down on
YouTube okay but then they put it back
up so it seems that the school you know
even though it's getting money from the
government was pretty much
you know intimidated well this isn't I
mean this is kind of like the a block
this is nothing new right every I mean
she is not anything radical even though
she claims to be a radical and a
revolutionary she's a cliche she's a
stereotype that has been coming out of
our colleges for decades that's the
worst part about it is that their their
brainwashed and diluted into thinking
that this is bravery when in fact
they're just going through the machine
and they're coming out exactly like a
cookie cutter you know thing they're
exactly like this there's nothing
earth-shattering or groundbreaking about
the things she says the stuff she has
regurgitated has been said by various
radicals to since the beginning of
radicals and she never knows what what
will be brought after this so-called
Revolution she's a Marxist she's a
nihilist but the most important thing is
she's brainwashed therefore nothing
anybody will say to her will ever change
her mind it's a shame that we're the
critics who are very vocal uh weren't
criticizing her while she was there I'm
sure there were some people there that
were pretty pissed off they didn't say
anything she'll probably get a job at a
law firm she's going to sue us she'll
take a box of course she will but you
know what what's scary she may sound
like a Marxist but she probably sounds a
lot like corporate heads and marketing
yeah it's true but you know what's
interesting you talk about people who
might criticize uh there is a tweet from
mayor Adams who was booed as he was
introduced at this graduation and he put
out a tweet where he says after her
speech apparently he was incensed we
cannot allow words of negativity and
divisiveness to be the only ones our
students here your reaction to that
Harold I agree look this doesn't sound
like the graduation speech I heard at my
law school graduation it's a very very
different speech we just celebrated the
lives of those who who gave their lives
for the freedom that we all enjoy
freedom is messy it's beautiful it's
hard to hold on to but one of the more
enduring and best parts of it allows us
to take risks and be imaginative she got
that part right she leaned a lot into
her world view which I don't agree with
but I think what all of us are saying at
least that what I extrapolate from
someone's being said you got to give
answers you got to give just just
painting this awful terrible picture is
something that's been done and sometimes
we need to be reminded of some of the
ugliness and I don't agree with the
things she talked about but she has that
world view if you have that view and I
would say to students and those in
Academia and even those in the private
sector offer answers that's what people
want and I don't think I agree with the
mayor wholeheartedly kids need to have
hear something inspirational Dana we all
do and as you talk about something
inspirational talk about how we solve
these problems and not just put uglier
and uglier pictures on the challenges
that we have I wanna Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now